not only are there many countries in the
west that would frankly rather not be
spending what it costs to support
Ukraine but also particularly in
Washington there is a a
growing almost Terror of what might
happen where Donald Trump to win the
presidency and certainly for some people
within the blob I mean I'm encountering
it in my own conversations with with
officials there is that sense of we
can't let this war roll on until it
becomes Donald Trump's playground we
actually have to reach some kind of of a
settlement before that point which makes
them really quite vulnerable to this
kind of suasion from Moscow